Marylyn matching algorithms for blood
donation yeah thank you very much so
I'll be talking today about some sort of
nascent work at Facebook looking at
designing a matching market for for
blood donation and this is joint work
with my student P my PhD student Duncan
McHale / she's in the audience
Christian Crower a variety of folks from
core data Sciences in econ see us at
Facebook co-directed by Nico's dire
Moses who's in the crowd and and and
Facebook social good as well and so we
have a very small working paper on some
of this and I'm happy to talk offline
about some of the stuff that we haven't
put sort of up publicly yet as well
great so safe blood is a scarce resource
and I emphasize safe here for a couple
of reasons that'll become evidence in
the coming slides so every two seconds
somebody in the US needs blood
developing countries specifically face
chronic shortages of blood and these
particularly impact children and
pregnant mothers and mothers who have
recently undergone childbirth
so children have severe anemia due to
same out malnutrition or malaria and
women have complications from pregnancy
or childbirth indeed over 99 percent of
roughly 500,000 women who died during
childbirth every year during pregnancy
are in developing nations and the
primary calls for this is some form of
hemorrhage which unsurprisingly involves
a significant amount of blood
transfusion and so if there's a chronic
shortage of blood then you're going to
also have a chronic issue with dealing
with these hemorrhage issues ditto
there is disparity between where people
live and where a blood donation occurs
so about 40% of the blood collected each
year is donated in developing countries
whereas over 80% of the world's
population lives in developing countries
and I have a little picture here from
Times of India this year on a world
donation day talking about the shortage
of blood estimated in India so this is
just one example
what donation so blood has to be donated
it can't be synthesized it has to be
donated blood donation is handled
differently worldwide and donation rates
and norms also vary worldwide and I just
have a couple of examples up here there
are a couple of very nice books and
papers that have come out recently from
Oxford there's a book called nine pints
that was written just kind of about the
history of blood throughout the world
that has a couple of great chapters on
the history of blood donation very very
interesting read I've just put a couple
of examples up here so in the US for
instance the u.s. mixes state and
private run donation so about 40% of
blood in the US comes through the
American Red Cross some surprising about
50% is going to come through community
donation centers and then about 10% will
occur via direct donation at hospitals
so that's sort of not surprising for
those of us who live in the u.s.
that is interesting yeah so state money
I guess is going into a lot of these
yeah yeah I should be a little more
direct with the way that I use this I
mean AARC is is formally a private yeah
that's right
China for instance has state control
over donation centers all right and this
is a function in part from around 1998
when a blood donation law was put into
effect that was basically meant to
standardize testing before blood
donation occurred there was a very
famous incident in China where tens of
thousands of people were infected by HIV
Laden blood because of lack of testing
basically of donors and so this well
donation law in 98 was passed to try and
regain confidence in blood donation
systems in China and actually had a huge
and very beneficial impact on donation
rates and they run a mix of quota and
volunteer based donation quota as in you
have to donate X amount of blood units
per year
pick another country Brazil donation
there is increasingly federally run
previously it was sort of state-run and
and this had the same sort of issues
that existed in in China and another a
bunch of other countries which is you
know people didn't trust the system and
so donation rates were down and an
issues with the blood supply rips and
recently they've shifted to foley
non-remunerated donation so donation as
opposed to paying for blood
well donation rates thus vary widely
across countries you can see actually
that donation rates and countries are
impacted by trust in the system so if
you look at like the UK or the u.s.
people generally trust the American Red
Cross or donation systems associated
with the NHS in the UK and so donation
rates are high and these drop for
example with income so if you look at
high-income countries about 3.2 percent
of people donate once or more per year
and this drops steadily to fall
low-income countries where only half a
percent of people donate every year
finally the World Health Organization
recommends that basically everything is
coordinated by by a nation at the
nationwide scale the entire blood supply
chain okay so this goes all the way from
blood collection which I'll be focusing
on in this talk to blood testing
processing storage distribution and so
on this is the full blood supply chain
and they recommend that this is handled
at least in a lightweight way via policy
at the nationwide level
one reason for this is that well it's
hard to get safe and regularly supplied
blood without some sort of high level
hand here
so one emphasis that if you look at you
know the AR C or WH o they really like
to pitch voluntary unpaid blood donation
as a method for getting safe blood and
this is backed up by a lot of research
so voluntary unpaid donors these are
folks who give blood of their own free
will without receiving any form of cash
or in-kind payment are the key to
ensuring safe blood donation this is
from the WH o and in O these voluntary
blood donors are also the safest donors
because they're already educated they
tend to donate multiple times they're
experienced they tend to live a
healthier lifestyle and this just makes
testing easier and better
great so I mentioned the full blood
supply chain this starts obviously with
finding blood donors who then donate
blood that blood is collected and
processed and tested this goes into say
storage for some number of days before
going bad inventory management and so on
and then finally into distribution and
actual transfusion in a hospital so into
a needy patient there's been a lot of
work in this space which is a good thing
because this is such a worldwide issue
there's a lot of operations research
optimization CS econ etc work that's
been done on the collection and
processing side the storage and
inventory side and the distribution and
transfusion side okay and so here's a
pointer to a nice recent lit review that
covers something like 120 papers since
the 1960 is basically written on this
chunk of the supply chain obviously
there has been some work on the donor
side but most of the optimization based
work here focuses on basically
predicting supply or predicting demand
so you know given a demand spike such as
a natural disaster how can I predict
supply of donors in a particular region
that sort of problem
so our work here is going to be the
focus on on just the donor recruitment
side so not the collection and
processing and so on so a blood donation
at Facebook I mentioned Facebook this is
a Facebook team that's that's right yeah
is the typical way in which this is done
is we have a certain stock a disaster
happens that we expect to use the stock
and then the new donations are just
replenishing the stock or is it more we
need the new donations in order to and
I'm sure there's heterogeneity it really
depends on the country so there are
there are countries that do not have a
steady supply of blood and in fact
basically when you get blood in the
hospital you're basically told hey you
need to replenish exactly the blood
units at exactly the type of blood that
you've got you know or will be angry for
some value of angry and that's not even
during the demand spike so that's just
the way their system works so doing the
demand spike you'll see you know like
whatsapp will light up with with blood
donation requests you know p2p basically
blood donation and so that's part of
what this is Facebook product is trying
to solve
so Facebook full donation product
connects millions of donors with
opportunities to donate in several
countries around the world so here are a
couple of quotes in June of 2019 from
Facebook's newsroom so this is public
information there were more than 35
million people who had signed up to be
blood donors on the platform in a
variety of countries at the time Brazil
India Pakistan and Bangladesh this is
since launched actually in in the US as
well so of some country some cities here
in the US for example DC where I live
are also able to now use this product
some initial work has been done the
survey impact of say Facebook products
on blood donations so centers in India
and Brazil found that 20% of people said
that Facebook influenced their decision
to donate blood according to in person
surveys conducted at those partner blood
banks and so this number you know it is
fuzzy obviously it's it's in-person
surveys it's in a particular country but
it's still an exciting measure noisy
measure of impact here great so what
does the product look like well you have
two sides of them sort of the market
here one is blood recipients I'm using
recipient here to say a hospital blood
drive a blood bank
even individuals and via this product
they can state their need and location
ok so I am at position X the hospital I
have a need for a particular type of
blood in this case the other side blood
donors these are you know the 35 million
plus folks who have signed up as blood
donors they can find donation
opportunities and can choose to receive
push notifications about those
opportunities so here's a lever that we
can play with when we notify somebody
who has signed up right so maybe they
have some budget for how many times they
want to be notified or maybe there's
some self-imposed budget on the firm
side in this case Facebook side that
says we will only push a notification to
a user once every K days say K is equal
to 14 or 21 so we can play around to
that lever to try and respond to
expressed in it
in this talk I'll be discussing the
primary research question that our team
has been focusing on which is notifying
donors to increase donations okay so
when do we choose to do this push
notifications subject to a set of
business constraints and how do we do
this equitably initially across the
recipients okay so no say single
Hospital that happens to be located in
an area very high population gets you
know all of the pushes and thus all of
the impact of this product how can we do
this equitably across recipients and
then eventually equitably across the
donors as well great so I'll pause here
any questions so far this is like the
hospital has some special need or Deven
spice and that's why they need so it's
this more for developing countries that
doesn't have a good system or is it more
for like say even in the US if there's
some special needs can you talk a little
bit more about sure so I'm gonna answer
that with the non exclusive or which is
yes to both of those so this product
came out of initially a focus on the
developing some developing nations so
let's focus on say India or Brazil so
here are our two countries and they have
vastly different donation systems but um
in India for instance PTP blood requests
are very common so I know I'm going to
the hospital I'll contact my my CI
social network you know my mom my dad
etcetera and I'll say you know for those
of you with a particular compatible
blood type can you please come to this
Center with me this this hospital with
me and provide blood that I need so that
was common on a variety of platforms you
can imagine SMS you can imagine other
other platforms as well and so this
product came out of basically trying to
do a better job join that matching
process now obviously if you're allowing
individuals to request blood why not
allow you know other you know blood
banks blood drives hospitals etc to
request blood and there are always going
to be shortages that occur sometimes
even in countries such as the u.s. where
the blood donation system is a lot more
organised but the the product initially
came out of that developing
Oh
so I'm a man with a hammer and that
hammer is matching so let's view this as
a matching problem problem description
matching supply and demand okay so we
have recipients these are the hospitals
or people you know some of them are
static hospitals don't tend to come and
go some of them are static like blood
banks some of them are also dynamic okay
so I could have a blood drive for
instance there might be in a world blood
donation day and June so there's
basically worldwide there's always a
drop in blood donation in May and June
for a variety of reasons and so I might
have a blood drive in May or I might
have ad hoc requests okay this is one
side these are recipients and I'm going
to call them recipients are and some
sort of time indexed set of recipients
okay so this can change with time
potentially we have supply in this talk
I'm going to treat this as a static set
of donors okay so we're going to assume
that there are a static set of donors
and people aren't arriving into party
that should be relaxed in the future and
they will donate with some probability
only after receiving a notification okay
so in this talk I'm going to assume that
they won't donate unless we push notify
them and if we push notify them then
with some probability that maybe we have
to estimate they'll then go to a
donation center and we'll get you know
utility from
so edges here are going to be potential
notifications that I can send and a
matching is going to be the selection of
some of those edges that actually result
in push notifications and these edges
again going to be indexed by time they
can change right a person maybe goes out
of the city for a week and edges to
donation centers in that city will
disappear and so on the weight is going
to be a probability of action all right
so unlike maybe some other matching
applications where probability is the
probability of this edge existing well
that's going to be I can just treat that
as a weight here as well right and these
will change over time
great so viewing this as an optimization
problem again we have a set of edges
that I can select from at a time T I'll
index edges coming out of a donor using
II D and edges going into a recipient
using ER and then we have edge weights
time dependent that we estimate from
data and this is actually a huge problem
in general which is you know how do i
estimate the probability that John if he
receives a push notification at time T
will actually go and donate to a center
right
I'll be using the standard decision
variables here which are going to say
given an edge e at time T I'll use a
binary variable and set it to 1 if I
choose to notify on that edge and set it
to 0 otherwise
and I mentioned some constraints some
one constraint I'll talk about in the
present lecture is a self-imposed
constraint which says that I can only
push notify a user I can only select an
edge in the out coin set of edges from a
donor every K time careens so say if K
is if I'm going matches and batches once
a day maybe I'll set K to 7 and I can
only notify once every 7 days once a
week we can write that as a constraint
saying I can only use my binary variable
associated with edges coming out of a
donor once or 0 times every t tiger or k
timeframes
so we're working toward defining an
optimization problem here we've talked
about decision variables parameters for
the model constraints what's the point
right we don't want to just find a
feasible allocation here we want to
maybe maximize some objective I'll focus
on two objectives here one is sort of
the obvious one which might be to
maximize realized donations what you
think we have a total weight of a
matching and it's going to be the sum
over all our time periods at the edges
that exist at that time of whether or
not we use them times the weight which
is the probability that they converted
and treating users either recipients and
or donors fairly is also important so we
can have different objectives that
encode forms of fairness here's one that
we're going to experiment on a bit which
is this maximun utility so this is going
to basically say hey given all of the
recipients all the blood banks are the
hospital's here's the utility what they
got I want to maximize the minimum of
that not saying it's the right one just
saying it's one that we could use
great so let me give a concrete example
matching problem very toy right we have
say horizon of three we're allowing a
user to be matched at most once every
three time periods so in this example
each of these three users can be matched
at most once in time period 1 we have
this hospital h1 that exists and can be
matched let's say everybody's within a
certain range to each of these three
donors and I've associated with this
hospital a single wait a 0.1 and that's
going to be for every one of these edges
for now in reality obviously every one
of those edges has its own unique weight
this is just a very tiny example in day
to a new recipient arrives say a blood
drive can be matched to anybody in the
pool still and then a day three two
folks leave and one new folks comes in
yeah in this twin ouvea original
formulation as well clearly that's a
constraint you can solve the day by day
he's asking if the only thing that
couples time periods
so we have a static set of donors on one
side of the market we have a possibly
evolving set of vertices V that can
arrive online on the other side and yeah
so one coupling point is whether or not
we've we've chosen to match a particular
donor in
not in the model that I'm talking about
in this talk that's right not in the
model that I'm talk about in this talk
so in reality yeah that answer that it's
very different yet so the rationale for
that constraint of notifications is that
just kind of one implementation of the
constraint that you can't do any but
everyday because no actually this is
coming primarily uh at least from my
understanding from not wanting to ruin a
user's experience with in this case the
product so there are going to be hard
constraints on push notifications for a
variety of of things you know even if
you could donate blood every one hour
then you wouldn't want to be pushed
notified to donate blood every one hour
it's actually assumption that people who
initially volunteer because I have to
sign up for this or people who are
publicly minded and then actually have a
utility to get one more donation push
them one more ad for some dumb product
that's absolutely right and in fact the
model that I'm going to talk about that
we're working to apply to this problem
is going to assume reusable resources
that where this this person gets matched
and they disappear for some number of
time periods that can be specific to the
user and may be drawn from a
distribution and that distribution could
be very short for somebody who say
socially minded and very long for
somebody else that's right that's right
absolutely not and this is a huge issue
yeah so yeah so this is this is a big
problem right is you can use proxy
events for example to try and you know
gain some insight into whether or not a
user acted on a push notification but no
no I mean I would love to see in the
future some sort of deeper relationship
with a blood center where you're able to
say hey you know for this set of blood
centers we in a specific city we hit a
bunch of say donors with with push
notifications who actually converted to
a donation but at the moment no answers
they like check all their options with
you okay
when they get the notification like if I
was notification I got a match to a
blood drive but it's too far away I want
to check if I have some other blood
drive doesn't hear my house we got the
opportunity to like search for answer
yeah so the base product if you if you
enter into that and again this might be
different across different countries
if you enter into that as a potential
donor then you can actually browse a
fairly long list and obviously it's
ordered in a particular way a fairly
long list of donation events and
requests and this is ordered by the
standard ordering that comes with lists
like this so the answer is yes in fact
yeah yeah so when you go to push
notification that'll take you into this
part of the product and then at that
point you know your one one click away
triggers somebody to donate but not
necessary
so does that mean it's nothing we're
actually have to do like sort of boots
on the ground there's a very sort of new
product like what time scale do
fluctuations in the reserves happen
that's right um quarter of say 30 ish
days for storing blood again this is I
hate to keep using this answer it
depends on the country this is an answer
I'm very familiar to you know give when
I talk about kidney exchange as well it
depends on the country but let's say
order of 30 order of some small number
of weeks but that small number of weeks
is actually set to be higher right now
than say the constraint that we can't
push to use there's more than K so it's
something greater than K at the moment
yeah and this also depends on the type
of product that you're getting from
blood you know blood vs. platelets
versus plasma burst of public
buh-buh-bah but let's say order of
multiple but not that many tens of days
how do you know when the donor is
actually off your sort of target
audience the kid is let's say they've
already donated so how do you know
whether you stopped or destroyed we
don't so if they donated outside of the
let's say that I went to a blood
donation center while I was walking to
science today I might still get a push
notification if I haven't been pushed
within these constraints I'm not sure
what the answer to that is I I can't see
a reason why that wouldn't be the case
though I mean you would hope so
great
down the rabbit hole the point I wanted
to make here is that there can be a
difference between our two objective
functions right if I take the total
weight matching in this very tight
example here then I might match all of
my users to the you know this particular
hospital here I might get a utility of
1.5 for that but if I look at the
maximum in utility well I have two
recipients that receive nothing and so
that's zero whereas if I choose say a
maximun policy omniscience you know I
know my entire role out here then I
might choose to smooth out the
notifications across my recipients which
will result in a loss in weight not
surprising to anybody here
so maybe starting to address the
question that was asked a bit earlier
well let's say that we are able to
perfectly predict for a given fixed
horizon we can perfectly predict the
existence of all edges alway it's all
recipients all donors it's not
surprising that we could write down a
nice formulation for this where I'm
going to incorporate into my objective
some sort of max weight matching plus
lambda times some function Q which is
going to encode some form of fairness
maybe some smoothing maybe some sort of
maximum utility etc if I write down to
some Nishant policy then you know maybe
I could solve for an optimal policy
given this this roll up
interestingly this is an np-complete
problem the decision problem is
np-complete for basically any
instantiation of the problem so if we
have this this K donor rate limit if
that's greater than 1 if I am disallowed
from hitting a particular user exactly
every time period if I want to so
basically no limit and for most
objectives that you would expect so as
long as my fairness function is is a is
a kind of function then I I have this
result here so if we're omniscience that
IP needs to be an IP and can get very
large so think Facebook's scale solution
I think that's true we haven't explored
that much simply because we're never
gonna use what we probably won't use
this I think that's probably true and
there's a lot of structure as well right
like 35 million registered donors you
know some number of tens of millions of
registered donors but the number of
edges are there's gonna be some
structure obviously to this right
there's structure to me being matched to
San Francisco area
yeah so you know if you're an IP person
you can start going to get
decompositions and maybe you could
actually solve this optimally not a big
focus right now though energy program
the heart okay great so we do have
distributional information we have
partial information and this is sort of
one push that we're taking right now for
this audience I'm not going to go into
this but you can imagine planning this
as you know a stochastic optimization
problem where we we go down sort of the
rabbit hole of doing optimization stuff
which even though they're talks of mind
this is something I really enjoy doing
but for this talk I want to connect this
back to say matching in theory but
before I do this are there any questions
on the model
so that's the problem we're trying to
solve how does this connect to some of
the things that we've been talking about
for the last couple of days you know
online matching from sort of a
theoretical lens
all right so let's talk again about one
sort of standard form of online matching
we have a bipartite graph U and V on
either side of this graph we have edges
between them we're gonna know you
entirely offline in the context of this
problem those are going to be my donors
V in this case will arrive sequentially
it's a one by one theorize one by one
this is already not realistic in the
setting because some of our recipients
exist for a long period of time for
instance Johns Hopkins isn't going to go
away after one time period and some are
right in batches as well but I'm going
to talk about open problems after this
we have a fixed T time steps and at
every step T could think of it as
representing demand shocks so you could
think you know let's say John taught me
is this all the time but a disaster
happens now Johns Hopkins needs forty
percent more blood that could be the
same as a pop-up donation place popping
up then these roughly forty percent of
what John I think that's right I think
that's right yeah so we would have some
clump of offline baseliner sort of
sometime I got yeah I think that's
absolutely right yeah in fact I would
love to talk about that more offline
because that's a little bit further
outside of my area of expertise again I
have my hammer and that hammer is gonna
be matching in this case but
yeah yeah I think that might be a nice
scalable way to handle this as well yeah
and then I say a blood drive could be
advanced sort of a demands migrate yeah
the problem but they don't shake it are
not the same so if you wanna learn the
fairness the baseline will guarantee
some fairness across all these hospitals
but maybe not in terms of the age for
the Amanda they might happen it's
important that's true oh yeah copy
but coming back to sort of standard
online matching which I'll then try to
cast a problem into so at every time
step T we have some sample of a vertex V
who arrives let's say independently from
some known distribution B okay so in a
lot of problems such as advertising or
this one we have a pretty good
distributional estimate of the
distribution from from which V might be
drawn in the center model we're going to
assume that the vertex V must be
assigned immediately and irrevocably to
a vertex on the U side right so a vertex
V arrives we choose to reject or match
that match is set in stone so in this
case that match would be a push
notification so if I decide to push
notify you at T I can't then remove that
push notification and most no deans at
time t plus 1 and then reallocate it
right standard assumptions T is very
large and V is very large relative to
the offline side you
and typically we have some typically
linear function f over the match two
edges II that we want to say maximize an
expectation all right so we're trying to
find some algorithm that finds a
matching that's going to maximize this
function over the matched edges
maybe the expectation of that so sort of
a fast and loose cast overview of the
standard online matching problem
so I'll talk about two papers that I
think are the closest to addressing the
problem that we're trying to solve and
they're both going to use reusable
resources so we're gonna take this
motivation which is that in many
applications offline vertices that you
side are gonna be matched and only
removed temporarily from the pool before
returning
rideshares a good example of this if we
consider the drivers to be offline
vertices then they're matched to a
request
you know maybe they picked the person up
there off of the uber app for 15 minutes
or if you're in DC for the next 75
minutes and then you reappear
you know never connect connection
management maybe there's an AP you're
connecting to ed your Rome and there's
another person connected so it fails for
a while into that person leaves or organ
allocation may be a recipient receives a
kidney and that lasts for some it's to
get a some draw write some in this case
integral draw time from a distribution
so there's been a couple of papers one
from our group a at Maryland and one
that I'm going to mention from groups
here in Simons
that are going to incorporate into this
model these reusable offline resources
okay so what does that mean we have an
offline bird X you if it's matched
according to an e an edge e it's going
to reappear later in time according to
some random draw from a known
distribution an integral draw
call that see
and I'm going to talk about the no and
iid case of arrivals here a couple of
papers including this one also extend
this into the know an adversarial
distributions case we have Muhammed here
in the front row so we can talk about
profit inequalities but for this setting
I'll just talk about Kait ec2000 fight
that they should walk down the hall and
the university we share at some point in
fun yeah I would love to see that cuz in
this paper and also in another paper
that comes from folks in the audience
I'll have a slide on I didn't see that
cited in either so coming from a known
distribution or okay item people I mean
their distribution it there are in one
of the agents but each should reusable
think they will commentate we say for
example Wi-Fi resource they say
Starbucks there are ten ports and then
each person is coming and takes some
number of units from for ten minutes or
one are they are using this resource and
then after that they yeah
so in that sense there is not initiating
distribution for the timing of that
resource but then the distribution of
the arrival of the agencies yeah I see I
think that's a little different I think
it's a little different to this I I'm
trying to cast this problem and I'll do
one minute cast into the stochastic
online scheduling which I think might be
more similar to the problem you're
talking about the motivation can be a
little different so we can actually
recast this problem in the language of
SOS stochastic online scheduling where
we have say non identical parallel
machines they're static we have V jobs
that are going to arrive sequentially so
at every time step T we're gonna sample
at most one job with some probability
each type of job is going to be able to
be processed non preemptively to use the
language of this world so this is
irrevocably once I assign it I can't
move it non preemptively on a subset of
you these are the edges between U and V
when a job V is assigned to a machine
you
we'll get some profit w/e this is not
the typical objective that's the
objective but we cast our problem into
the space machine you will be occupied
for some number of rounds this world and
I Mohammad maybe could dive deeper into
this as well
the motivation is typically a bit
different and the the model is typically
a bit differently what we're talking
about - so the motivation here is
typically in a minimize may expand and
we're looking to maximize some weight
and maybe do some sort of fairness as
well
so the benchmark we're going to use I
guess an interest of time I'll sort of
breeze through this is going to be the
competitive ratio higher is going to be
better the expectations were taking over
both of the numerator and the
denominator here are going to be over
randomness of both the algorithm and the
arrival sequence in the numerator and
then in the denominator just over the
arrival sequence so it's sort of the
standard competitive ratio you would
expect for the same
so we'll take a common approach to
designing alga the two separate the
algorithms into two phases first we're
going to obtain an upper bound on an
offline optimal solution an LPA then
online we're going to use the solution
to that offline upper bounds will sample
from it it's some fractional or it's a
probability distribution we'll sample
from it and we'll use it to guide our
online matching algorithm so in our case
actually the stochastic of this problem
makes computing an offline optimal
solution tricky and so we rely on a
bunch of intuition from other similar
problems of which there are many the
nice paper in stochastic knapsack by MA
in 2014 and some folks in stochastic
matching as well so we want to design
out and we want to do that using
information from some sort of upper
bound on opt so if I knew right infinite
computation I can create some sort of
optimal algorithm that's gonna do maybe
the best I can do an expectation okay so
here is an LP that is an upper bound on
the expectation of opt it's exactly what
you might think in this case we're just
for exposition we're ignoring the
fairness constraints here we want to
maximize the sum of the weights of the
edges that we use subject to a couple of
constraints one is the probability that
V is matched at any particular time T is
upper bounded by the probability that
that type of vertex arrived at time T
right remember that we have access to
this information and I can change based
on T but we know that information so the
probability that an optimal matching
actually uses an edge is going to be
upper bounded by the probability that
the the source of that edge actually
exists at that time and the second
constraint and this is sort of the the
trickier part is well have another bound
that says the probability that U is
still unavailable based on a previous
assignment plus the probability that I
end up matching T has to be bounded by
by one right the match against raining
so remember once I match an edge to a
vertex on the U side the offline side it
disappears for
random draw integral random door before
reappearing to be matched again so this
is a an upper bound on the expectation
of opt we can use this in the standard
way to design an algorithm a non
adaptive algorithm with a with a
competitive ratio guarantee that I'll
give ok
so let's solve that LP offline we have
distribution information that gives us a
probability distribution over edges and
then we'll sample from this in the
online face so we use a simulation based
algorithm to do this I'm gonna be
parameterised by a desired competitive
ratio that we show this is valid up to
0.5 simple algorithm so a vertex V
arrives at time T look at all of its
edges call the ones that can be used so
that are matched to you that are still
in the system safe if that edge set is
empty you can't do anything to reject V
otherwise take all of those edges that
are safe and a sample one with this
probability and that's kind of an ugly
probability so I'm going to walk through
it with little blue arrows one is we're
going to sample an edge with higher
probability if it's more likely that an
optimum algorithm would use that edge
we're then going to sample it with lower
probability if it's more likely that you
know that vertex is really likely to
arrive at that particular time then
we're gonna say well you know maybe I
don't want to match this edge as much is
it some sort of rare vertex arrived
we're going to sample with higher
probability if we're shooting for a
higher competitive ratio and then we're
going to use this beta term which is the
probability that an edge is safe at a
particular time T which is to say the
probability that the sync node the you
node is unmatched at probability at time
T and you can just learn that via
simulation
so is the intuition behind the PPT
coming from the fairness considerations
no because here we're just at least for
this talk we're only maximizing some of
the weights of the edges that were
matching yeah that's right so our
motivation here was actually in
rideshare initially and I'm I am gonna
talk about some edits that we need to
make to this model before replying to
blood donation now this is really
interesting
Google Scholar actually this morning
recommended a recent working paper from
two months ago from folks in the
audience here and I think it's actually
looking at a very similar problem so I'm
not sure if I've seen at least Rawdon
and a min here I'm not sure if either of
them are in the audience but they
actually look at two different models in
the assortment planning setting one of
which I think is exactly the same as
what we're looking at okay so they have
a prior free model where vertex types
are drawn from arbitrary distributions
and we have a Bayesian model which i
think is actually identical to our model
so this is kind of cool to see there
paper goes into a lot more depth in a
different different sort of set of steps
than ours but we actually derive the
same competitive ratio of 0.5 using a
simulation based algorithm from a
similar LP upper bound of the expected
version of opt and then they also do
some stuff with adaptive policies so it
was nice to see this paper basically
we've come up with the same results
which is pretty cool cool so why was I
talking about all that well that's to
sell this problem in part to this
community because neither of those
models can be adapted immediately to the
blood donation problem so both of those
papers derived 0.5 tentative ratio
relative to that LP upper bound but it's
not immediately applicable to the real
donation case
we have a lot of assumptions here that
might be broken right one is can we
actually assume that our requests are
much much bigger than our offline
vertices it's unclear maybe we can play
around with whatever request means it's
unclear how to set T we require
extension to the batch setting which is
multiple V arrivals for every T alright
so this is both sort of a realistic
constraint just because of the size of
the system but also a constraint on the
back end because maybe there's a batch
job processing that occurs every T time
periods behind the scenes at say
Facebook to actually do these sorts of
matchings we need to imagine revela pool
assignment assumption because some of
these vertex is vertices on the online
side are actually there for quite a
while right a blood donation blood drive
does not appear and disappear in a
single time period it maybe exists for
quite a while or maybe there's a
hospital that exists permanently and
none of this stuff has actually looked
at the fairness definitions or any sort
of uncertainty on like the weights of
the edges that come in right the value
of the edge if we happen to mention
so those are works in progress in the
interest of time I'm going to kind of go
through some of the initial policies
we're trying in reality and then I'll
leave you with some open problems that
we can discuss federally interesting to
the community so those I think are the
two closest theoretical models to our
problem we're working on extending them
for now though because this is a
real-world problem we can also
experiment with some just heuristic
policies for doing matching okay so come
back into the sort of real problem that
we're trying to solve what can you
imagine doing right well we have donors
who are signed up for the program we
have recipients we could just choose
them randomly right the the most
heuristic of the heuristics probably
this is varied of recipients probably
assuming some distributional assumptions
but probably doesn't maximize weight and
that's the same result that we'll see in
reality which I won't talk about in this
talk and also in simulation which I will
talk about you could also imagine doing
some sort of max weight myopic matching
right so sorry selection of edges visit
donors in a random order and then choose
from all of the safe edges for that
donor good sir if they if we visit them
then they're safe from all the edges
that donor the one with the highest
weight the one with the highest
conversion probability probably not fair
to recipients because there's gonna be
these say hospitals that have a higher
rate in general because they're say
located very well probably pretty good
in terms of maximizing short-term weight
and you can imagine other sorts of
heuristics round robins on the recipient
side join some sort of like epsilon
greedy style thing on the donors side
these are all heuristics that will
result potentially in some sort of
middle ground between total weight and
fairness so we have these parameters
like how random you are across the
recipients and now random you or across
the donors you can learn this from data
saying basically how can we balance this
right and there's very little overhead
in terms of optimization we're not
solving a big in at your program we're
not solving even a big linear program
offline to guide search yet
so in terms of simulations for this talk
this is not real data but we've actually
created some simulations that look like
real data so we create a city where
people live we create some donation
centers and we draw edges between the
city between the the donors and the
recipient maybe based with some weight
based on based on that distance and we
find again these are reasonably
realistic that the heuristics actually
perform as we would expect random
donation selection does very badly in
terms of both efficiency and fairness
round-robin on the recipient side does a
little bit better in terms of fairness
but worse in terms of total weight and
searching for max weight by selecting
donors is going to do a pretty good job
in terms of weight and actually behind
the scenes if you compare this to the
offline optimal it's actually doing
pretty well compared to that which is
pretty nice to see so one open
theoretical question we have is that
given realistic distributions perhaps
greedy does a pretty good job relative
to offline optimal but it does badly on
parents
and I'll leave on a complimentary issue
and some early conclusions basically
saying that one of the big issues here
is actually not matching at all it's
just estimating those edge weights to
begin with so what's the probability of
converting it's even estimating that
right we don't have access to whether or
not somebody in the past actually did
donate based on the push notification
and we also like having this off by a
little bit can create a huge issue when
it comes to telling how well your
implementation is actually done right
likely we can't measure these direct
donation events you can use proxy events
based on say notification engagement or
search behavior to determine this but in
reality I think this is actually going
to be sort of a boots-on-the-ground
problem where we have to figure out by
talking to donation centers what the
conversions actually looked like okay
and even though I have my matching
hammer that I've repeatedly talked about
my hunch here is that improvements here
can actually help a lot more than
improvements in the matching policy
itself so this is a nice complementary
issue conclusion we're developing a
notification policy for donors we're
interested in increasing donations yes
but also equitably doing this to donors
and recipients in theory most forms of
this problem aren't be hard but what
we've been seeing in our launch is
actually that heuristic solutions are
very good here there are a lot of
interesting problems that we could look
at as a matching theory community and
there's the unsurprising trade-off
between overall edge weight and fairness
but we want to be able to parameterize
and select that and so if you want to
here open problems talk to me offline
questioning that graphs you should from
your simulations the levy max wait it
looks kind of like a meat preserving
spread around your office that might
also be a byproduct of the the
distributions were drawing from it's
very very sort of smooth so we smooth
things out to be able to talk about them
in this talk so we've lost a fair amount
of information that might be the case
though yeah risk attitude you know the
max that's gonna be good if you are more
risk-averse you want the you know less
barrier but I don't know something with
this point I think that absolutely is I
would want to suss out exactly the
distributional like the simulation yeah
yeah that's very important data okay
well thank you very much we're going to
take a 10-minute break and then we'll
have our last part of the date Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]